and have a chance to talk with tyler as
he continues to offer clarity and
closure from the world beyond take a
look
my job as a medium is to deliver
messages i can't stress enough how proud
she is of you tyler congratulations on
everything so far and this is just
another exciting step in your journey
let's talk about the netflix show and
how it all came about for you
yes well thank you you know it's been
really an interesting journey it
happened as i was recovering from a
collapsed lung as the pandemic was
breaking out uh i had the opportunity to
basically travel the country once it was
safe
and start meeting with people who had
inquired in the 300 000 person waiting
list from my initial show
so that was so fulfilling to be able to
actually travel to places where people
normally wouldn't be able to come to l.a
surprise people it was really
multifaceted and i felt really where my
ability could shine was with regular
folks
and let's talk about it this show is a
lot different than your previous show
you really get into your family and your
storyline how special is that for you to
get to explore that you know whole new
world and journey for yourself
it was definitely intense kind of
turning the tables on me and exploring
my family history that aspect of
vulnerability and really trying to get
answers to something that just presented
more and more questions so it gave me a
newfound appreciation i think for what a
lot of the people
feel when they're actually receiving the
reading that sense of wonder that need
for clarity and i found myself kind of
going through a lot of the same emotions
yeah i'm sure you had a lot of important
takeaways as you went through this
process but what are you hoping that the
people who are watching take away from
it this is a new experience for all of
us to witness from you
absolutely you know one of the beautiful
things about readings is i think there's
something that everybody can relate to
in different readings some more than
others and so i hope that the general
takeaways though the show is focused on
people who've passed i think there's a
lot of valuable lessons about what it
means to be alive and what it means to
be human and you know so often the
people that see me have regret uh regret
of what went unsaid or undone
and so i think that it's important when
watching the show to kind of view it
from that lens as an opportunity a
reminder
to really validate the people in our
lives in the here and now while they're
still with us to really minimize the
likelihood of regret in the future and
you've had so many amazing experiences i
can only imagine you know some of your
favorites that might stand out to you
but is there a moment that you really
keep close to heart or something that
will always just stick with you forever
absolutely you know so many readings
have those commons but i would say when
it comes to my reading with rupe hall
that was one of the most overwhelming
for me rupaul was somebody i looked up
to as you know a kid growing up in a
small town uh not seeing much
representation and so to be able to
connect with him a little later in life
and be able to provide him some healing
when he gave me so much just by existing
uh it was really meaningful to kind of
have that full circle moment
yeah that's it's really